[Music]
I'm full of Christmas I don't know what
it is but it's like inside a house it's
no Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
goddamn I cannot bear that I'll buy all
things are they green accumulating
thousands of dental cannot be taught
ruin my life making it the best
Christmas yet don't play those Christmas
carols until my ears will bleed with
Christmas cheer
and I'll scare the shit out of you but
it's only getting bigger every year
does it snow we love shopping
Sanchez get the shit out of because I'm
fucking batshit crazy about Christmas we
paid in hot chocolates and my skin is
random
it still your solid business entity of
appeals and appeals in the Steel's
embassy keep it longer make a stronger
nothing wrong here I can stay here
something safety
the guys feeling wire - fire I'm a buyer
right
by the way the songs available on our
tune
I want to smash it open - it's different
gold and it's urgent great French
Christmas goal in the trinkets blood
type lose control
don't ever fucking do that again I'm
sorry he has is a sickness they're gonna
be cured by repression and tranquilizers
yeah it's fucking scary
it's no I love shopping and I fought for
falafel king love Christmas enough to
build tranquilizer immunity I must be
fucking batshit critter Missy What did
he say I'll kill anyone not celebrating
with me you're resistant to feeding my
insanity does this no big so what the
star atop the tree and find me a funky
TV work going on
boy that did feel good thanks so much
you guys hey Jesus
[Music]